es posible que a usted o a un ser
querido les hayan diagnosticado cáncer
de sangre este video lo ayudará a
entender cómo puede lidiar con dicha
situación el cáncer de sangre También
conocido como cáncer hematológico
comienza en los tejidos que producen
sangre tal como la médula ósea la médula
ósea es el tejido esponjoso que está
dentro de los huesos y que produce
células sanguíneas o el cáncer de sangre
puede comenzar en las células del
sistema inmunológico los siguientes son
ejemplos de cáncer de sangre la leucemia
el linfoma y el mieloma
múltiple los tratamientos tales como la
quimioterapia la radioterapia la terapia
dirigida la inmunoterapia y el
transplante de células madre pueden
controlar los cánceres de sangre
dependiendo del tipo de Cáncer y otros
factores es importante contar con un
plan de atención no solo para recibir
tratamiento y atención personal sino
también por motivos de seguimiento esto
incluye programar y asistir a citas de
control además de controlar su bienestar
y estado General de Salud el médico
verificará si hay signos de reincidencia
y detectar cualquier problema de salud
que pueda haber causado el
tratamiento por ejemplo es posible que
se realicen pruebas y estudios de
imágenes incluyendo la toma de muestras
de sangre del líquido alrededor de la
médula espinal o de la médula ósea para
controlar la presencia de cáncer tal
como su situación lo requiera continúe
tomando todos sus medicamentos tal como
lo indique su receta no deje de tomar
los medicamentos sin consultar a su
médico es útil Tomar nota sobre los
puntos a discutir en la próxima visita
al médico estos pueden incluir los
efectos secundarios que haya
notado si recibió tratamientos como
quimioterapia radioterapia o transplante
de médula ósea siga las instrucciones
que le
proporcionaron hay cambios de estilo de
vida que podrían mejorar su salud y
ayudarlo a sentirse mejor dejar de fumar
tiene sus beneficios reduce el riesgo de
que el cáncer regrese o se
disemine se cree en general que una
dieta saludable puede ayudarlo a
sentirse mejor y más fuerte durante y
después del
tratamiento actividades físicas tales
como caminar andar en bicicleta o nadar
pueden ayudarlo a que se sienta mejor y
menos cansado hable con su médico antes
de Iniciar una rutina de ejercicios
saber que uno tiene cáncer puede ser
abrumador puede tener preocupaciones
sobre la afección Y qué tanto podría
enfermarse como esto afectará a usted y
a su familia los tratamientos las
hospitalizaciones las facturas médicas y
su trabajo hay maneras de encontrar
apoyo recuerde que su médico y su equipo
de atención están presentes para
responder cualquier
pregunta puede encontrar apoyo usando
los siguientes recursos trabajadores
sociales líderes religiosos consejeros y
grupos de apoyo hable con su médico si
tiene preguntas sobre su plan de
tratamiento sobre los medicamentos o
sobre los cambios de estilo de vida que
lo ayudarán a controlar el cáncer de
sangre